mom who are these people it was an
innocent question from my young daughter
alia around the time when she was three
we were walking along with my husband in
one of Abu Dhabi's big fancy malls and
he was peering at a huge poster standing
tall in the middle of the mall it
featured the three rulers of the United
Arab Emirates as she tucked in my side I
bent down and explained that these were
the rulers of the UAE who had worked
hard to develop their nation and
preserve its unity she asked mum why is
it that here where we live and back in
Lebanon where Grandma and Grandpa live
we never see the pictures of powerful
women on the walls is it because women
are not important this is probably the
hardest question I've had to answer in
my years as a parent and in my 16 plus
years of professional life for that
matter I had grown up in my hometown of
Lebanon the younger of two daughters - a
very hard-working pilot and director of
operations for the Lebanese Lebanese
Airlines and a super supportive
stay-at-home mom and grandma my father
had encouraged my sister and I to pursue
our education even though our culture
emphasized at the time that it was sons
and not daughters who should be
professionally motivated I was one of
very few girls of my generation who left
home at 18 to study abroad
my father didn't have a son and so I in
a sense became his fast-forward a couple
of decades and I hope I didn't do too
badly in making my father proud of his
would-be son as I got my bachelor's and
PhD in electrical engineering they are
in the in the UK and consulting in the
Middle East I have always been in
male-dominated environments truth be
told I have never found a role model I
could truly identify with my mother's
generation wasn't into professional
leadership there were some encouraging
men along the way but none knew the
demands and pressures I was facing
pressures that got particularly acute
when I had my own two beautiful children
and although Western women love to give
us poor oppressed Arab women advice they
live different lives with different
constraints so Arab women of my
generation have had to become our own
role models we have had to juggle more
than Arab men and we have had to face
more cultural rigidity than Western
women as a result I would like to think
that we for oppressed women actually
have some useful certainly hard-earned
lessons to share lessons but might are
not useful for anyone wishing to thrive
in the modern world here are three of
mine there is this word that everybody
is touting as the key to success
resilience but what exactly is
resilience and how do you develop it
I believe resilience is simply the
ability to transform into fuel in
my previous job well before my current
firm I was working with a man we will
call John I had teamed up with John and
was working hard hoping he would notice
how great I was and that he would come
to support my case to make partner at
the firm I was in addition to delivering
on my consulting projects writing
passionately on the topic of women
economic empowerment one day I got to
present my research to a roomful of MBA
students John was part of the audience
listening for the first time to the
details of my study as I proceeded with
my presentation I could see John in the
corner of my eye he had turned a dark
shade of pink and had slid under his
chair in a parent shame I finished my
presentation to an applauding audience
and we rushed out and jumped into the
car there he exploded what you did up
there was unacceptable you are a
consultant not an activist I said John I
don't understand I presented a couple of
job Jen to parity indices and some
conclusions about the Arab world yes we
do happen to be today at the bottom of
the index but what is it that I said or
present
that was not factual to which he replied
the whole premise of your study is wrong
what you're doing is dangerous and will
break the social fabric of our society
he paused then added when women have
children that place is in the home time
Stood Still for a long while and all I
could think and repeat in the chaos of
my brain was you can forget about that
partnership Leila it's just never gonna
happen it took me a couple of days to
fully absorb this incident than its
implications but once I did I reached
three conclusions one that these were
his issues his complexes there may be
many like him in our society but I would
never let their issues become mine to
that I needed another sponsor and fast I
got one by the way and boy was he great
and three that I would get to show John
what women with children can do I apply
this lesson equally well to my personal
life as I have progressed in my career I
have received many words of
encouragement but I have also often been
met by women men and couples who've
clearly had an issue with my husband and
I having chosen the path of a dual
career couple so you get this
well-meaning couple who tells you
straight out at a family gathering or
either friends gathering that come on
you must know you're not a great mom
given how much you're investing in your
career right I would lie if I said these
words didn't hurt my children are the
most precious thing to me and the
thought that I could be failing them in
any way is intolerable
but just like I did with John I quickly
reminded myself that these were their
issues their complexes so instead of
replying I gave back one of my largest
smiles as I saw in flashing lights the
following sign in my mind's eye
you see as a young women in these
situations you have two options you can
either decide to internalize these
negative messages that are being thrown
at you to let them make you feel like a
failure like success is way too hard to
ever achieve or you can choose to see
that other's negativity is their own
issue and instead transform it into your
own personal fuel I have learned to
always go for option two and I have
found that it has taken me from strength
to strength and it's true what they say
success is the best revenge
some women in the Middle East are lucky
enough to be married to someone
supportive of their career correction I
should say smart enough because who you
marry is your own choice and you better
marry someone supportive if you plan to
have a long career still today the Arab
man is not an equal contributor in the
home it's simply not expected by our
society and even frowned upon is not
very manly as to the Arab women our
society still assumes that her primary
source of happiness should be the
happiness and prosperity of her children
and husband she mostly exists for her
family things are changing but it will
take time for now it means that the
professional Arab women has to somehow
maintain the perfect home make sure that
her children's every need are being
taken care of and manage her demanding
career to achieve this I have found the
hard way that you need to apply your
hard earned professional skills to your
personal life you need to work your life
here is how I do this in my personal
life one thing to know about the Middle
East is that nearly every family has
access to affordable domestic help but
challenge therefore then becomes how to
recruit effectively just like I would in
my business life I based a selection of
who would support me with my children
while I'm at work on a strong referral
kostina
had worked for four years with my sister
and the quality of her work was well
established she is now an integral
member of our family
having been with us since tania was six
months four
she makes sure that the house is working
with running smoothly when I'm at work
and I make sure to empower her in the in
the most optimal conditions for her and
my children just like I would my best
talent at work this lesson applies
whatever your childcare situation
whether an au-pair nursery part-time
nanny that you share with someone else
choose very carefully and empower if you
look at my calendar you will see every
working day one and a half hours from
7:00 p.m. to 8:30 p.m. UAE time blocked
and called
family time this is sacred time I have
done this ever since Tonya was a baby
I do everything in my power to protect
this time so that I can be home by then
to spend quality time with my children
asking them about their day
checking up on homework reading them a
bedtime story and giving them lots of
kisses and cuddles if I'm traveling and
whatever the time zone I used to type to
connect with my children even if I am
miles away our son Rohan is five years
old and he's learning to read and do
basic maths
here's another confession I have found
that our daughter is actually more
successful at teaching him these skills
than I am it started as a game battalion
loves playing teacher to the helath to
her little brother and I have found that
these sessions actually improved poor
hands literacy increased Ilia sense of
responsibility and strengthened the
bonding between them a win-win all
around
the successful Arab women I know it had
each found their unique approach to
working their life as they continue to
shoulder the lion's share of
responsibilities in the home but this is
not just about surviving in your dual
role as a career woman and mother this
is also about being in the present when
I am with my children I try to leave
work out of our lives instead of
worrying about how many minutes I can
spend with them every day I focus on
turning these minutes into memorable
moments moments where I'm seeing my kids
hearing them connecting with them Arab
women of my generation have not been
very visible in the public eye as they
grew up
this explains I think to some extent why
you find so few women in politics in the
Arab world the outside of this however
is that we have spent a lot of time
developing a social skill behind the
scenes in coffee shops and living rooms
on the phone a social skill that is very
important to success networking I would
say the average our women has a large
network of friends and acquaintances the
majority of those are also women in the
West it seems like ambitious women often
compare themselves to other women hoping
to be noticed as the most successful
women in the room this leads to the much
spoken about competitive behavior
between professional women if there's
only room for one woman at the top then
you can't make room for others much less
lift them up Arab women generally
speaking have not fallen for this
psychological trap faced with the
patriotic Society they have found that
by helping each other out all benefit in
my previous job I was the most senior
woman in the Middle East so one could
think that investing in my network of
female colleagues couldn't bring many
benefits and that I should instead
invest my time developing my
relationship with male seniors and kids
yet two of my biggest breaks came
through the support of other women it
was the head of marketing who initially
suggested I be considered as a young
global leader to the World Economic
Forum she was familiar with my media
engagements and my publications and when
she was asked to voice her opinion she
highlighted my name it was a young
consultant a Saudi lady and friend who
helped me sell my first project in Saudi
Arabia a market I was finding hard to
gain traction in as a woman she
introduced me to the clients and that
introduction led to the first of very
many projects for me in Saudi
today I have two senior women on my team
and I see making them successful as key
to my own success women continue to
advance in the world not fast enough
but we're moving the Arab world to is
making progress despite many recent
setbacks just this year the UAE
appointed five new female ministers to
its cabinet for a total of eight female
ministers
that's nearly 28 percent of the cabinet
and
more than many developed countries can
claim this is today my daughter ideas
favorite picture this is the result no
doubt of great leadership but it is also
the result of strong Arab women not
giving up and continuously pushing the
boundaries it is the result of Arab
women deciding every day like me to
convert it into fuel to work their life
to keep work out of their life and to
join forces and not compete as I look to
the future my hopes for my daughter when
she stands on this stage some twenty
thirty years from now is that she be as
proud to call herself her mother's
daughter as her father's daughter my
hopes for my son is that by then the
expression her mother's son or mama's
boy would have taken on a completely
different meaning thank you
[Applause]
[Music]